start a question for you what is too
much fat on a ketogenic diet this comes
up over and over and over again like how
much Factor I need to consume in their
mind 75% of your calories need to be fat
is a tremendous amount of fat and
they're a little bit freaked out because
they don't want to die of a heart attack
or a clogged artery so let's just kind
of cover that so we need to create a
balance of just the right amount of fat
versus too much fat okay if you have
hypoglycemia if you have low blood
sugars you're gonna need more fat
because your your main problem is you
can't go from one meal to the next
without being very hungry so if there's
a blood sugar issue it's gonna take more
fat because we want to add enough fat to
go from one meal to the next if you're
eating too much fat what's gonna happen
it's gonna overload the liver and
gallbladder and the pancreas because see
the gallbladder breaks down the fat into
a small these small particles but the
pancreas releases an enzyme called
lipase which takes it from that small
particle down into the smallest particle
so if you're have a blood sugar issue
and your pancreas is exhausted or you're
diabetic you're not going to be able to
produce as many enzymes thereby
stressing the body so when you have too
much fat you're gonna feel more bloated
nauseous you're gonna have more right
full sensation on over the gallbladder
on the right side through here it's
gonna stem up to the right shoulder
blade through here to the neck headache
maybe the eye and might even create
tension you up your neck word causes
pain on the right arm I've seen that as
well so in the beginning you're gonna
need a little bit more fat because you
haven't fully adapted the switch between
sugar burning and fat burning isn't
clean enough now when you do this over a
long period of time you're going to
switch very easily to fat burning sugar
burning back and forth so the need for
fat is going to be less and less but
here's the thing if you have too much
fat the fat that you're burning that's
coming out through ketones in your urine
could be the dietary fat not necessarily
your own fat so even though you're in
ketosis
you're not losing weight
because you're burning mostly their
dietary fat and not your own fat but if
you keep doing it and you keep adjusting
the fat to the sweet spot where you can
go from one meal to the next comfortably
and not overdo it with the fats
you'll start tapping it into the fat on
your body and this dietary fat won't be
an issue it won't interfere with your
ability to really get into a full
ketosis where you're burning off your
fat and one last mistake that a lot of
people make when there's when you start
ketosis is they they don't do in a
minute fasting they will have this idea
they can have unlimited fat so they make
these little cookies out of the fat like
called keto bombs and they're just
picking out on these things in between
the meals at the meals at night and
they're wondering it's not working I'm
not losing weight so that's just because
they're fat they're burning is the
dietary fat and at their own fat so you
want to combine in a minute fasting with
the ketosis not go crazy with the fats
but have enough to get you from one meal
to the next and if you have blood sugars
you can need a little bit more but as
you do this over time it'll be easier
and you can cut down in some of the fats
and you'll feel comfortable and you
won't be hungry and you'll lose weight
all right thanks for watching
hey thank you so much for watching keep
spreading the word and share this video